we got the story from the post
millennial Trump Giuliani and others to
be booked at Fulton County Jail suspects
in Fulton County are booked and
arraigned on two separate occasions so
according to standard procedure Donald
Trump will be in County lockup a not so
special prison the left calls it
decrepit and say people die there
so I have a few questions how do first
how do they handle something like this
but more importantly
what would happen
and everyone's saying it won't happen so
fine sure whatever I'm not saying it
will happen I'm saying question what
would happen if with these charges
Donald Trump his associates or any one
of these individuals refuses to go to
Georgia and surrender what happens then
fugitive charges
so there's interesting constitutional
provision and it's it's it's really just
absolutely hilarious the armchair people
on Twitter who have no idea what's going
on in this world and think they know
everything and that's not everybody I'm
just saying they exist
one person brought up a really good
point saying the Constitution says if
someone flees from Justice then the feds
can intervene to bring the person back
to that state but what if you're not in
the state and weren't in that state in
the state accuse you of a crime the
legal argument is that you are fleeing
from Justice by not surrendering but
this would mean if Donald Trump Sydney
Powell Jenna Ellis or any one of these
individuals refuses to surrender their
state would have to cooperate law
enforcement would have to be sent out by
Joe Biden to take in a former
presidential Administration official or
lawyer and bring them to Georgia to be
brought to jail
what happens
it's interesting Rhonda Santa said that
he would not assist in any extradition
of Donald Trump
Donald Trump of course is currently in
Bedminster but what if he goes down to
Mar-A-Lago it would be awesome Tim it
would be just the most awesome thing
ever to see that it would I mean and it
would be terrible for the country I'm
aware and there are people that are mad
I don't know that's true either
he goes like push the envelope make them
come get you I want those I want the
feds I think I think they should have to
go serve documentation to Trump I think
Donald Trump
not going to get a fair Shake in uh
Bedminster he's up in New Jersey good
luck with that I think Trump his perfect
play is to go to Florida
make DeSantis
put it put his money where his mouth is
and this is not a dig onto Santos it's
like do you have the the Integrity to
uphold what you've said but more
importantly if Georgia has an issue they
don't deliver this via press conference
on TV if they're going to a restaurant
they have to go to his residence and
serve him the arrest documents this is a
it's such a strange phenomenon that
people are like Donald Trump should go
surrender yeah if they serve him legal
paperwork
and say hello Donald Trump here's the
legal paperwork you can take a copy of
it bring it to your lawyers you have to
you can surrender in 10 days or you will
be arrested all right what's happening
now is this lady goes on TV and says we
expect them to surrender in 10 days
that's not legal you can't go on TV and
be like I'm suing them it's like okay
well until I actually have legal
documents saying I'm being sued with a
court signature and all that stuff
you're not doing anything for all Trump
knows there was never even a grand jury
how's he supposed to know that how is he
supposed to probably knows prosecutor on
TV and is just like come on down Trump
and she can take a picture with him and
smile get autograph
unless I'm not literally suggesting
that's what she's doing but for Trump
and all these defendants
their lawyers are going to have to be
served some kind of paperwork or
documentation and I think the smartest
play for Trump is to go to Mar-A-Lago
and just say
if you are charging me you can deliver
the documents to my residents where I
will answer for them and then we will
discuss terms of either surrender or a
legal challenge yeah and I mean Trump
was acting in his Federal capacity
during this entire thing as like a
Federal Officer so I'm not even
convinced that a state has the authority
necessarily to arrest him for something
like that I guess we'll see it might go
all the way to the Supreme Court but
what they're doing to these folks is
just despicable I mean my colleague Jeff
Clark is one of the one ones who's been
indicted
um along with President Trump acting
assistant uh attorney general yeah I
mean wow
wow no it's absolutely Bonkers and he
was just providing legal advice right he
was just telling Trump this is how I
think that you could apply the law and
for that crime which is not even a crime
right they're saying it is it's totally
Preposterous well Jenna Ellis I think is
the funniest because she's being charged
with just being Trump's lawyer right
that's that's basically it
by just being his lawyer they're getting
they're charging her with uh Rico yeah I
mean that's I I firmly believe it's
about intimidation it's a like I said
last night it's it's about the
establishment wanting to intimidate the
population including lawyers you know
anyone and anyone that might run in the
future
like these are talented people that are
going to be put on the sidelines while
they have to deal with all of this
that's the point but I want to I want to
speculate here what do you think happens
if they don't surrender
is it something really boring like a guy
shows up knocks on the door and says I
have a warrant for your roast and they
go okay and then they get in the car and
they drive off I don't know who the
Secret Service actually answers to
because if the Secret Service answers to
Donald Trump the Secret Service are
armed and they'll be they'll have plenty
of of gear to actually pose a serious
threat so if anyone is gonna go pick up
Donald Trump and the Secret Service
actually answers to him as opposed to
answering to DC and they listen to him
and he says don't let them come take me
we could have a SWAT team with a gun
fight with or an FBI hostage rescue team
in a fight with secret service and
gunfight with secret service over Donald
Trump if that's if that's how world war
three or whatever starts I never saw
that coming civil war well that's what
how Civil War you never know I mean I I
and this is all just you know a dude
that yells at a stick for a living
talking out of his ass so take it for
not like it which is nothing it's worth
nothing but I mean you know like I I
don't know how the the the Secret
Service how the the yeah with the
command structure is exactly so I don't
know what happens but it if it is it's
possible but like because the Secret
Service is supposed to protect Donald
Trump and even if Donald Trump does get
picked up and and goes to jail none of
that takes away the fact that he's got
Secret Service protection for the rest
of his life so that means that there's
going to be secret service he's gonna
have to be in a special jail
some type of special jail and secret
service is going to have to rotate in
and out of his cell because they're not
going to leave him alone with a cellmate
you can't like he's got Secret Service
protection for the rest of his life you
know but the Secret Service his own
secret service if he were to start
committing murder like starting to
murder people on the street his own
secret service would have to stop him I
would imagine They don't serve him they
serve the law in the in the post
president I don't know that the Secret
Service is obligate I would assume the
guy the human being that is the Secret
Service Officer like or whatever if if
Donald Trump said to start just mowing
people down I assume he would stop him
that being said I don't think the Secret
Service is any more obligated to stop
someone that's committing a criminal act
then the regular police are and the
regular police are not obligated the
Supreme Court has decided that they're
not so I don't know that they that they
would be obligated to stop him but I
would assume that a normal human being
in in the role of secret service officer
would probably stop the Fair former
president but I'm killing people there
are people right now saying on Twitter
that to end this right now Donald Trump
need refused to surrender publicly State
he will challenge us to the Supreme
Court that one the actions they're
challenging him on are protected as he
was president at the time and that the
leaking of the indictment before the
grand jury voted proves that this is a
political conspiracy to steal or seize
power there's a legal argument not the
way I described it there's a legal way
to describe it improper unconstitutional
actions or something like that
some people have said Trump can Trump
and Republicans can end this right now
by doing what needs to be done I don't
know if that's if I agree with that I
don't know what would happen I have no
idea for all it's entirely possible that
what the Democrats are trying to do is
muster up some kind of reaction so that
they can use it to justify more if Trump
doesn't surrender they then go and say
he's a fugitive from Justice and that
instantly justifies the removal from his
name of his name from The Ballot or
something like that
maybe Trump says okay we go to court
then he files a bunch of extensions he
files to have a transfer to Fulton uh
out of Fulton County to uh federal court
like what Mark Meadows is doing and that
delays the process until the election
takes place and his name says in the
ballot that might be the correct
strategy for this it does seem like they
will all be surrendering Giuliani for
instance said that he's planning
sometime next week to go down my
question is what would happen if they
don't and then you know if Trump stays
in Florida for instance for one that
puts tremendous pressure on Ronda Santos
I don't know if Trump wants to do that
because Santa's already falling in the
polls
however it does create pressure it would
force DeSantis to defend Trump which can
either put descendants in a difficult
position where now he's 100 on board
with Maga and Against the Machine the
opportunity there is is DeSantis really
anti-deep state or whatever well here's
your opportunity if Trump then refuses
and says serve me the paperwork and my
lawyers will negotiate then he has time
without going to jail no mug shot no no
jail time and then he gets the Supreme
Court to issue a ruling on it and crush
it instantly before they can pull off
whatever weird scheme they want to pull
off
I don't know I have no idea what happens
here's what I prefer I guess if uh I
suppose the simple surface level uh
response I could give is I think Trump
would be better off not surrendering and
simply saying
I have not received any legal
documentation or notification in my home
state of any charges against me from
anyone else
the simple Act of a press conference is
not a legal uh declaration that gives
them the authority to take any actions
when my local law enforcement make
contact with my attorneys as per any
pending charges or extradition another
state I will absolutely respond with
legal documents that's what he should do
and he should do it from Florida not
from New Jersey although the defender
supporters want Rhonda Santos to throw
him under the bus so
I don't know what you get with that I
think too we have to remember like
questioning an election's legitimacy is
something that has happened throughout
this country for you know centuries
almost I mean Jackson questioned his 24
election and would reportedly walk
around talking about how it was stolen
you had Bush you had Stacey Abrams
countless individuals do this sort of
thing when there's evidence of
widespread fraud or they think there is
evidence of widespread fraud in Trump's
case there actually was massive fraud
whether that was you know the censorship
of the hunter Biden story and how media
kind of co-opted Voters access to
various sources of information on the
Biden family or whether that was you
know a pipe bursting in an Atlanta
ballot count Center I like cheating
better than fraud yeah because fraud
some people you say that people might
think cheating but some people might
think legal fraudulent actions like fake
battles and stuff cheating is better the
shadow campaign to steal the election
that Time Magazine published that's
cheating withholding the hunter Biden
laptop cheating changing the rules at
the executive level without approval
from the state legislature cheating what
they're doing right now by arresting
Donald Trump his lawyers and the former
presidential administration's personnel
cheating I like cheating better I like
the word manipulating but I think we're
all right I mean I think I don't know if
it's technical fraud either but I think
it's both cheating manipulative and
cheating I mean you could say it's cheap
get a man on the street go to time the
thing is it didn't break the rules yes
it did just change the rules it did
break the rules oh then it is true yeah
so the Constitution says that the state
legislature has final Authority on how
the elections are run and how electors
are assigned and when you got Governors
changing the rules without the approval
of the state legislature and courts
bypassing the state legislature that was
in violation of the Constitution thus
Texas filed a lawsuit under original
jurisdiction to the Supreme Court saying
the way that these states handled their
elections violates the Constitution and
thus it it uh descript it's it's uh what
do they say basically it's stripping
Texas of their right to a free and fair
election if other states are violating
the Constitution the Supreme Court just
said screw you we don't want to hear it
so instead of actually hearing the
arguments on the merits the Supreme
Court just had to leave us out of it why
because they're evil and corrupt people
and cower Thomas and Alito I think were
the ones who were like we must hear this
argument yeah they were afraid to
because they were afraid to hear the
argument and then find in favor of
Donald Trump because it had there was
Merit to it and it was like it wasn't
even in favor of trump it was Texas
saying if we do our elections by the
Constitution and Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin and Georgia and Michigan or
whatever don't then there was no
legitimate election yeah it's like
basically saying you and 10 of your like
you and 10 of your buddies are going to
decide who how much money you pitch in
by lunch and then one of your friends
just gives a bunch of counterfeit bills
and you're like no no no why am I
spending twenty dollars we all agree
everyone puts in 20 bucks 20 bucks
wasn't real or at least I don't know if
it was real and they say nah shut up you
don't you don't get to there were
articles written or about like the
discussions they had about whether or
not they would take like this and they
were concerned about the reaction the
population would have if they found in a
way that would help Donald Trump they
were really really concerned about it
that the Supreme Court Justice Jenna
Ellis yeah I don't have it is being
criminally indicted under Rico charges
for the simple Act of being Trump's
lawyer
Mark Meadows was Trump's chief of staff
former presidential Administration chief
of staff was indicted for that reason
these people in the Supreme Court were
probably pissing in their pants sitting
in the corner crying begging for
forgiveness saying I'll do whatever you
say
Clarence Thomas was like nah and I think
I think it was Alito and Thomas who were
like screw that we don't care thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time